en temps normal les athlètes canadiens
auraient vécu ceux ci l'entrée dans un
stade en étaient bondées les frissons la
fièvre des jeux
c'est plutôt une entrée bien solitaire
au stade de montréal pour antoine
valois-fortier pandémie oblige un rendez
vous raté pour le judoka et médaillé
olympique
c'est certain que ça fait un petit
pincement au coeur le gie 30 en ce
moment donc j'ai plus j'en ai plus de
fait qui me reste à faire dans mon cas
donc j'avais une très bonne saison le
momentum était de mon côté j'étais prêt
pour cet été et pas de mots si j'ai
tellement et de crèvecoeur dans toute ma
carrière qui le sait comme un autre
coeur ça fait quinze ans que joelle
bekhazi tente de se qualifier pour les
jeux avec son équipe de water polo
après trois tentatives la quatrième a
été la bonne
puis la pandémie samra émotive juste à y
penser
donc pour moi ça va être vraiment triste
de ne pas avoir ce moment l'ex hanegbi à
tenter de se qualifier à 29 ans pour
l'entrée officielle de la planche à
roulettes aux olympiques
si elle ne craint pas l'année de plus
elle est consciente du facteur temps
dans ce cas une bonne c'est pas trente
ans que tu attends pic de performance si
je peux dire le fait que c'est sûr que
pour moi ça rajoute une année
d'incertitude c'est par rapport à ceux
de ses potentiels bhl est ce le retour à
l'entraînement a été éprouvant antoine
valois fortier et son équipe doivent se
rendre en alberta pour pratiquer le judo
là aussi permis de quoi chambouler les
plans pour celui qui n'est toujours pas
qualifié sa vie racheter une pression
supplémentaire ça vient rajouter de
l'importance
être en mesure de faire les bonnes
choses c'est certain car les deux
oreilles ça peut devenir difficile
parfois on est dans l'inconnu on est
dans le brouillard beaucoup la pandémie
et reprend de la vigueur et le comité
organisateur insiste pas de vaccin pas
de jeu y aura-t-il des olympiques en
rien n'est moins certain mais la chef de
mission du canada se fait rassurante
mais garde espoir en considérant ce qui
a été accompli au cours des cinq
derniers mois
tous les athlètes le répète il préfère
se concentrer sur ce qu'ils peuvent
contrôler mais le risque est cruel
les jeux pourraient bien être annulé ça
va me détruire un peu j'aurais juste
avait très difficile pour me ramener
remonter c'est sûr que ça ça fait partie
de pensée qui a peut-être pas de jeu du
tout c'est sûr que ce serait vraiment
dommage parce que je pense je pense pas
que c'est réaliste pour moi à 29 ans de
penser qatari 2024 c'est un peu trop
loin
chose certaine s'il ya des jeux en 2021
ce sera en soit l'occasion de célébrer
une victoire contre la pandémie et si
diane sauvé radio-canada à montréal